after six years here as a student and
six years here as a teacher it's with a
lot of mixed feelings that I'd like to
announce in 2014
I'll be leaving dangerous to become head
teacher mathematics at cherrybrook
technology high school as you may be
able to imagine the reason I'm feeling
so mixed about this is because on the
one hand I'm super excited about this
opportunity I love teaching because of
the astonishing positive influence
teachers can have on students and over
the past few years I've come to
recognize the astonishing positive
influence that had teachers and deputies
and principals can have on teachers and
being leader of any kind is a massive
privilege and so I'm really eager to
lead and serve in this new position but
on the other hand I'm leaving a place
and I'm leaving people who mean so much
to me for better or worse
Reus is a part of who I am and a really
big one it's because of some of the
amazing teachers that I've had that I
wanted to pursue a career in education
and it's because of the incredible
students I've met that I want to stay in
this career I'm going to be so much
about coming to this school every day
before I say more I want to apologize I
desperately wanted to share the news
with all of you in person but due to the
timing of how everything happened the
news didn't become official until after
school it ended and so I couldn't make a
big announcement in some ways I think
that may have been for the best I'm
really bad at farewells but there are
some important things I want to say
there's some particular groups of people
and that's why I'm making this video
first to my dear 11 class I'm so sorry
to be leaving you especially at this
point in time I know you're expecting to
have me next year and I was - I know how
frustrating it is to have your teacher
leave you just as you're starting year
12 because it actually actually happened
to me as well
my year 11 math teacher retired at the
end of year 11 and so I know exactly how
you feel the only consolation I can give
you is that unlike me and my year 11
class if you ever miss the feeling of
having me teach you a concept or a skill
I have been working over the last year
and a bit to make sure it's a place
where you can go to experience that
almost as if are in the room there with
you and you know what it's probably
actually even a little better because
you can just skip the boring rambling
parts so all the best for next year and
really looking forward to hearing how
you go in the HSC please work hard and
do me proud sue my IBT class it's been a
hilarious couple of years learning all
about database management systems
network topologies and more social and
ethical issues and you can poke a stick
at
I love teaching technology so it's with
some sadness that I reflect on the fact
that it's very possible I may never
teach IPT again No thank you for giving
me a really high note to end on to ICF
what I love most about being a teacher
is seeing how people start school in
year 7 as these cute little people
getting lost in such a big school and
then watching you grow and become
intelligent personable decision-making
adults when you leave in your 12
it's an incredible process to watch and
I've gotten to see it most clearly again
and again in you even though I've been
your leader and coordinator I want to
thank you for teaching me so much I'll
miss you but you know better than anyone
that this isn't the end whether it's in
one sense or another I'll see you again
soon lastly to everyone I've ever taught
coached or even just had a conversation
with over the last six years I'm kind of
overwhelmed by the whole turn of events
but one thing I'm really certain about
is the sense of gratitude I have for all
of you thank you for learning things
even when you had to be dragged in
screaming to start with thank you for
trusting me when I demanded high
standards of you because I knew you
would meet them before you did thank you
for accepting me when I made mistakes
thank you for greeting me with a smile
thank you for letting me play a small
part in your journey through life and
really thank you for everything
take care James Bruce